hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his tragic sense of life miguel de
uno muno is going to
say something in chapter 2 that many
readers
will probably prove a bit of a shock
perhaps even a scandal
or a stumbling block he's going to tell
us that
reason is a social
product and now remember he's telling us
this
you know over a hundred years ago and
in a context in which uh european
culture and
the culture of the west has really
become self-aware of how contingent
it is not just including its you know
technological developments but perhaps
we might even say the technology
of the human mind and that would include
the faculty
of reason a lot of people when they hear
people
saying things like reason as a social
product are very
worried that we're denying that there's
anything in human beings
that's determinative that's that's
universal we're saying it's all just
purely cultural that that you know
reason
would be as we say socially constructed
and unimodal thinks that
you know like a lot of people point out
that saying something is socially
constructed doesn't mean it's just
purely uh you know a product of culture
you wouldn't would actually agree with
them and he's you know
following to some degree as well in the
footsteps of of genealogists like
nietzsche in pointing this out and
perhaps you could also say
jean-jacques rousseau but he's got a
somewhat different
take on it and why do we get so worried
in hearing this sort of thing because of
of two big issues one is that there's a
tendency
to see reason or rationality
as what is distinctive about us
as human beings as opposed to other
animals how are we
not the same thing as those you know
whatever animals happen to be vital
you know complexes meat machines pick
whatever
theory you like how is there a
distinction between us but then the
other big thing is
this tendency to see reason in a very
abstract way
as something that's like totally
universal every human being has a
faculty of reason
and that faculty of reason has to be
more or less the same in everybody
i mean some people obviously children
it's not completely
engaged but it's their potential it'll
come into actuality
but we also see it as like completely
individuated so like reason
exists in this person here and in this
person here
and that's where the total likeness
comes about and if you think about that
that idea
that's a crazy idea there's no evidence
for that whatsoever
right we do all sorts of testing on
people
and those tests are at best proxies for
what happens to be going on
in their brains at this particular point
in time when they sit down in this
artificial condition
to take those tests there's you know we
can theorize about there being like a
universal faculty of reason
and every single human being but it's
not like a motherboard that's been
churned out in a factory and should have
exactly the same parts although as we
know
because this is the whole reason
customer service exists for computer
companies that's not the case
there's always things going wrong as
well so
let's come back to uno muno's view he
says reason
the distinguishing mark of the human
being
according to most philosophers obviously
he thinks that affectivity
is just as important is a social product
he says why he says we don't
live alone we're not an isolated
individual but a member of society
there's not a little truth in the saying
that the individual like the atom is an
abstraction
yet yes the atom apart from the universe
is as much an abstraction as the
universe apart from the atom
and the individual maintains their
existence by the instinct of
self-preservation society owes its being
and maintenance
to the individual's instinct of
perpetuation of love right
he says from this instinct or rather
from society
springs reason and then he's got this
phrase
reason that which we call reason reflex
and reflective knowledge the
distinguishing mark of man
is a social product
you don't get reason as reason
apart from people living in society
and developing within society
so he's got some interesting theorizing
here about language and one the probably
the key
element of that is articulateness um
he says that perhaps reason owes its
origin to language we think articulately
that is reflectively
thanks to articulate language and this
language why do we have language in the
first place
arose out of the need of communicating
our thought to
our neighbors you have language so that
you can
communicate you don't you don't first
have a faculty of language
and then you know you're like oh well
this would be really handy for
communicating
no it arises out of a situation that's
already social in which we're involved
with
others other human beings who are not
the same as ourselves
and we have to communicate meaning the
meaning of our thoughts the meaning of
hey watch out for that fire
the meaning of you know that
saber-toothed tiger let's go kill him
or run away from him or whatever it
happens to be
so he says to think is to talk with
oneself and each one of us talks with
himself
thanks to our having had to talk with
one another
we are not first and foremost isolated
individuated
things that only then begin to
communicate with others
first we're in a situation of
communication
and then we start to say things like i
and you and i want you to give me that
thing over there
or whatever else it would happen to be
so he says in everyday life it
frequently happens we hit on an idea we
are seeking
and succeed in giving it form that is we
obtain the idea drawing it forth from
the midst of dim perceptions which it
represents
thanks to the efforts which we make to
present it to others
so reason is is as he says social and
common
a fact pregnant with consequences he
says
reason is both social and common now he
also says something
else that's quite fascinating about not
just
language and reason but um
what makes us who we are so he's
talking uh here and this is also in
chapter two
uh about reason right and
uh imagination now typically
in philosophical anthropology that is in
or philosophical psychology arrangements
of the the faculties
and understanding of them typically
we've said that imagination is
less important than reason or
intellection that
imagination can go wrong you know so
descartes for example
will be a typical example a
representative of somebody
who really says imagination that's where
where we we get all of our mistaken
ideas from
reason will lead us to the right stuff
reason
removes itself from imagination and
that's how it works
better or intellection however you want
to put it cognizing
so that's not actually the case for
for um una muno he's telling us
something
quite different he says that uh
here we go this social sense the
creature of
love the creator of language of reason
and of the ideal world that springs from
it is at bottom nothing other than what
we call
fancy or imagination now notice the
prioritization
in there the creature of love the
creature of of the desire to reproduce
this attraction and affection that we
have
for other members of our species
this social sense is a product of that
and then it also creates language and
reason
over and over again within us that is
fancy or imagination
so that's basing
everything on you know something that a
lot of people would find quite
quite disreputable quite dangerous he
says out of fancy
springs reason and if by imagination is
understood a faculty which fashions
images capriciously
i'll ask what is caprice
the senses in reason are also fallible
caprice means
arbitrariness sort of
things contingency things just happening
to turn out that way
whim is another word for caprice
and so you could say well imagination is
capricious so we shouldn't trust it
but so what if imagination is capricious
so is reason
so are the senses we have to trust
something
so you know maybe our freedom actually
lies to some degree
in that capriciousness he also talks
about this
as an inner social faculty
the imagination which personalizes
everything
and he talks about it you know is like
revealing to us
uh god and the immortality of the soul
then says god is
a social product for that reason right
we're going to put that aside and just
think about this
an inner social faculty that
personalizes
everything part of what it means to live
in
in a world informed by the imagination
is that this may be wrong sometimes
we attribute a kind of agency and
personality
to things other than ourselves other
than animals
and we even do this with ideas so
that is an important aspect of this and
you can you can see this sort of
going on even in the most hardcore
supposed rationalist they treat reason
itself as if it's a deity
who tells us things so they're really
relying on the imagination as well and
he's got a chapter about the rationalist
called the
rationalist dissolution he talks about
how rationalists can sometimes
be you know rabidly anti-theist
he talks about an anti-theological fury
right
uh and that's kind of irrational too and
then he says there
those who don't succumb to that are bent
on convincing human beings that there's
motives for living in consolations for
having been born even though there shall
come a time at the end of some tens or
hundreds or millions of centuries
when all human consciousnesses have
ceased to exist
this is what he says some call humanism
and then he says that
this is the amazing product of the
affective and emotional
hollowness of rationalism and its
stupendous hypocrisy
a hypocrisy bent on sacrificing
sincerity
to veracity sworn not to confess that
reason
is and here's a key phrase a dissolvent
and disconsolatory power
and again we can liken una muno here to
kierkegaard or dostoyevsky or nietzsche
these earlier existentialists
who very clearly realized that
rationality doesn't always if we follow
it out
culturally doesn't always provide us
with you know sort of an
optimistic point of view as a matter of
fact reason this is part of what kant
was actually demonstrating
can show us the limits of reason
and the imagination and the
understanding and how easily we go wrong
and
nietzsche blew that up on a sort of
social level
as well there were others before them in
whom
you know we could say we can see
something similar
going on so rationalists
don't realize what reason is really up
to
in some cases unamuno himself
in a really key chapter at the center of
the work
called in the depths of the abyss tells
us a bit about his own project
in a very important way that ties in
with with reason
so he tells us here
he who looks for reasons strictly
so-called scientific arguments
technically logical reflections
may refuse to follow me further
anybody's right you don't have to read
the book you don't have to continue out
of the argument
right reason doesn't actually compel us
in the ways that people think it does he
says throughout the remainder of these
reflections on the tragic sense
i'm going to fish for the refl the
attention of the reader with the naked
unbaited hook
whoever wishes to bite let him bite but
i deceive no one
and he goes on and he says if in that
which follows you shall meet with
arbitrary
apothecams brusque transitions in
consecutive statements veritable
somersaults of thought do not cry out
that you've been deceived
we're about to enter if it be that you
wish to accompany me
on a field of contradictions between
feeling
and reasoning and we shall have to avail
ourselves of the one as well as of the
other we need both
reasoning and feeling in order to make
progress in philosophy and then he says
that which follows is not the outcome of
reason but life
though in order that i may transmit it
to you i will have to rationalize it
after a fashion
and then here he after referring to walt
whitman
he actually says that i'm not the
begetter of the fancies i'm about to set
forth
by no means they've also been conceived
by other men if not precisely by other
thinkers
who have preceded me and have exhibited
their life and given expression to it so
again
reason as a social product coming out of
the fancy relying on some of the
insights of others is a part of being
rational and then here's the crux of
where he's going
does this mean that in all that follows
in the efforts of the irrational to
express itself there's a total lack of
rationality
no the absolutely erratically
irrational is it inexpressible is in
transmissible
and here he coins an important phrase
but
not the contra rational so there's a
difference between the irrational
and the contra-rational he says maybe
there's no way of rationalizing the
irrational but there is a way of
rationalizing the contra-rational
that is by trying to explain it once
again
the the act of communicating with
another person
is part of how rationality plays itself
out he says since only the rational is
intelligible really intelligible
since the absurd being devoid of sense
is condemned to be incommunicable
you will find that whenever we succeed
in giving expression and intelligibility
to anything apparently irrational or
absurd
we invariably resolve it into something
rational
though that it be into the negation of
that which we
affirm so this tells you what his own
process and self-understanding of
the product in this book is intended to
be
reason is understood as not something
that we just have
you know fortunately within ourselves is
like our own set of tools
no it's something that we share with
others
by virtue of the fact that we are social
creatures
and we also have this imagination which
could be an individual imagination it
could be the imagination
of others that we rely upon or it could
be some sort of social imagination
so this is a very nuanced and
um i would say arguably important
conception
of reason rationality that which is
supposed to be essential to human beings
you